Okay let's begin to look at each of
our data quality metrics in a little more detail.
We'll start by looking at the validity metric. Here
we are primarily concerned with individual field values. For
example, we might have fields that are mandatory
there must be a value there. We might have
fields that must have a unique value in each
data item. We might have fields with foreign-key constraints.
An example might be product records. Each of
which must have a reference to a manufacturer. And,
that manufacturer must exist in our database. We might
have cross-field constraints. What I mean by this is,
essentially conditions on multiple fields. So, for example,
the start date must come before the end date.
Now for most fields, we're also going to be
expecting a specific data type. Or, a particular structure
of some kind, if we're talking about JSON data, where fields
can have values that are themselves dictionaries or arrays. We might
also have fields that we expect to have a particular patterns,
a pattern we can test using regular expressions. Some fields will
have values that we expect to be in a certain range.
This might be a numeric range that we can do bounds
checking for, or we might be talking about set membership of
some kind, so all tee shirts have to have a size
field that's small, medium, large, or extra large.
Auditing validity is about determining what the constraints
are on individual fields and checking to make
sure the field values adhere to those constraints.